[Music]
hey you guys once again time for tomes
of terror my little book review show now
this book was another recommendation
from one of you guys i can't remember uh
who it was because it was a while back
that somebody recommended it i had heard
the author's name before john lagan
but i had never read any of his stuff so
somebody recommended this book to me i
don't even remember what the context
context was but i guess whoever like
recommended that they pretty much like
know my taste because i really really
liked this uh a great deal so this book
first came out in 2013
and it's actually a short story
collection uh some of the stories are
like pretty short but most of them are
like novella length so i think there's
only nine stories in here there's like
two that are more that are really short
that are more like vignettes but the
rest of them are like pretty much
novella length
and uh it's called the wide carnivorous
sky and other monstrous geographies now
i will say that if you are really really
into weird fiction particularly like
lovecraftian type stuff then you and you
haven't read this guy then you will
probably really really dig it now
from the notes and stuff that i read uh
and interviews and stuff with him that i
read there were like at the end of this
book he's actually kind of in the same
writer's circle and is friends with some
other authors that uh whose books i've
covered on this show previously like uh
paul tremblay who i think i reviewed his
book the cabinet at the end of the world
he also read a head full of ghosts most
famously which i have read but i don't
think i've reviewed it yet and he's also
friends with uh nathan balangrid who
wrote wounds
uh which i believe i reviewed on here
too so he's kind of like in that circle
i believe his day job quote unquote is
like a professor at a college and that
comes through very uh very stridently in
the writing i really like he has very
elegant prose like it's very elevated
but it's not pretentious you know what i
mean it's actually quite beautiful and i
really do like i don't know i just
really liked the rhythm of uh of how he
writes his stories
now so as i said this is nine stories i
will say pretty much i really really
likes this a lot some of the stories
obviously are better than others or i
liked more than others uh the first
story i the only criticism that i could
give to this book and this is very minor
is that i kind of wish that they had put
this story like somewhere else in the
book i understand why they put it first
because this story which is called kids
is
not even really a story it's more like a
vignette type of situation
and when i first read it i mean
basically all that happens in it is
there's a teacher and he's in his
classroom and all of a sudden like all
these kids come in who are not his
students like they're much younger and
they proceed to like eat him so they're
like zombies
now uh so i was just kind of like okay
uh you know but then when i read because
there's writer's notes at the end where
he says like where the you know where
the ideas for the story came from and
like you know what anthology it
originally appeared and or what he wrote
it for um i actually really like that if
you're an author that writes short
stories or even if you write novels uh
keep in mind like other writers like me
uh i really do dig when writers put [ __ ]
at the end where they say they got the
ideas from because that's like really
interesting to me i do it in my short
story collections as well and i like
when other writers do it too
so this story as short and seemingly
plotless as it is the story behind it
was actually quite funny because i
didn't realize this but the teacher the
who gets eaten by the kids in the story
is actually um a real guy like a real
writer named jack haringa
and apparently what ended up happening
was that he i think that like jack ringo
was like in kind of uh like was
depressed or whatever and a bunch of his
writer friends got together and said
let's cheer him up by writing a short
vignette or short story about him
getting killed
and we'll put it all on our blog we
won't say anything about it but we'll
all put the stories on our blogs like on
the same day so it'll like freak him out
but it's also kind of cheer him up i'm
like that's kind of cool because that
seems like something that horror writers
would do
and i thought that was kind of amusing
so that's uh so essentially that's what
it was there's a bunch of different
writers who wrote
different ways like short stories or
vignettes about how this actual real
life person this writer like bought the
farm like they all posted them online
like the same day uh as a surprise for
him and he thought it was
he thought it was very very funny and
they actually uh collected all the books
into a little
into a small little volume called uh
jack karinga must die so i thought that
was like pretty hilarious but yeah so
the first story like i said it's it's
almost kind of like an appetizer i guess
so
again i can see why they put it first
now the next one this one's very
interesting and like i said this is
what's kind of cool about this writer
and i'll definitely be checking out um a
lot of people said he had another uh
short story collection that came out
before this one was actually that was
actually really good as well and he's
written a novel
uh you know and he might have written a
few more since then but i'm not really
sure i'm just going because this came
out in 2013 so i was reading the stuff
like prior to that
but uh so the second one is he really
likes to like experiment with form i
don't want to say that the stories are
like deconstructed necessarily because
that sounds
again pretentious and they're not really
but he does kind of like to
it just it it's kind of experimental in
its in its way like you can follow the
[ __ ] and you know it's not that out
there but he seems very interested in
playing with the tropes of horror
fiction playing with just literary
tropes literary formats in general and i
really like that so i like that each of
the stories kind of has its own sort of
like thing going on where he was like
experimenting with some different kind
of like uh with some different kind of
structure
so the second story is called how the
day runs down it's also a zombie story
which i'm not super a fan of but the
reason i dug this one was because
essentially what he did
was he took the very famous thornton
wilder play our town which i actually
read in school
and
rewrote it as though it was like during
a zombie apocalypse you know what i mean
so he has like the stage manager if
you've ever read the play there's like a
stage manager that's talking about all
these things that are happening and then
there's like these vignettes of all the
people in the town and so it's like that
but instead of this being like the
little sleepy town of grover's corners
or whatever it's basically like a zombie
apocalypse and it's also like a little
bit meta because there's like an
audience and the audience are like
zombies too it's like i don't really
want to spoil too much about it but yeah
so that was like a pretty cool story as
well especially if you've read our town
which like i said i did
a couple i read in school and then i
read it again since then so it's so it's
kind of cool to like see
that play like through the lens of like
a zombie
like a zombie apocalypse was actually
pretty entertaining now the next story
okay now this next story it's it's kind
of like in the running with the last
story that's in it is for my favorite
one
the next story is called technicolor
and this one actually appeared uh if you
know anything like if you're a big
horror reader like i am then you've
probably read a like an anthology
that's put out by ellen datlow uh edited
by her
she does those years best horror you
know she's one of the editors on that
and she puts out uh you know her and her
compatriots they put out like tons and
tons of anthologies every year on
different themes
so they had done a uh they had done an
anthology where you were supposed to
write something that was inspired by a
pose story not like a pastiche not like
write something as though it was a pose
story but take something that's like a
that's a poe you know concept or a pose
story and like do your own thing with it
so technicolor was written for that and
that's what it first appeared i think
the i think the anthology was just
called poe i can't remember right now
but uh it got like a lot of buzz this
story in particular did
and uh so what john langan did was he
took the story mask of the red death
which he said is his favorite pose story
and it's mine as well um and i've
actually written i wrote a novel called
red menace which actually had it wasn't
based on a pose story but it did have
like a mask of the red death little kind
of uh homage in it
so i was kind of like oh i see where
you're going with this i like it
so what this one is it's basically
told from the point of view a lot of his
stories i guess because he's a professor
and he's in academia a lot of his
stories are kind of like based in that
uh in that situation in that milieu if
you want to say that if i'm even saying
that right i don't know i'm trying to
like sound smart i guess but yeah um but
yeah so a lot of his stories are like
kind of set in academia
so this story is actually told this was
so good
this story was actually told from the
point of view of professor giving a
lecture to a class
and he starts out talking about mask of
the red death
and he posits i mean this story is just
like so
well
researched and just so it'll like really
make you kind of when you're reading it
you just kind of like go back go wait is
that real i just like i'm gonna have to
look that up and i saw like some other
reviews and stuff it was like i totally
like looked up like the real [ __ ] that
he was talking about and he's like oh he
just made it up but you know what i mean
so uh so yeah mask of the red death
supposedly
was based on not based on necessarily
but the thing of his uh lecture in the
story
is that edgar allan poe got the idea for
the colored rooms like the suite of
rooms in mask of the red death from this
like creepy
book that was written by this guy who
was maybe like some kind of occult
you know kind of thing
and uh it's really i really liked the
description of like this book and it had
like these weird
drawings in it that you could only
really see like when you shined like the
appropriate color light on them and [ __ ]
like that so it's like this really
complicated
kind of like occult ritual type thing
going on and it's really really long and
like i said it's really well researched
and it's so
convincing that
like i said for a second i was just kind
of like wait did edgar alpo really base
this on like a real guy like a real
occultist or something like that like
obviously i don't believe in like the
supernatural kind of elements but i was
like well that sounds kind of like you
know that sounds legit but then i was
like no of course not but it's just like
a really great story so like i said it's
framed like a lecture so it's like um
a teacher talking to a class about the
history of
where mask of the red dead came from
about the history of this occultist and
like how edgar alpo ended up reading
about him stuff like that so the story
is called technicolor and it's really
really good
uh so then you have a story called the
wide carnivorous sky
which is the title story
now this one it's kind i want to say
nominally this is another thing that i
like about him because i try to do this
in my stories as well
is that you take something like one of
the
you know cliches or horror tropes like a
you know particular monster and then you
try to like do something completely
different with it so this one
is nominally a vampire story but this
vampire is kind of more like
it does have some vampire like it has a
lot of vampire uh attributes
but it has a lot of differences too in
the sense that it's nothing like your
and race kind of vampires where they're
all kind of like fancy and aristocratic
or anything like that this is much more
like it's intelligent but it's much more
like a predator also he said he wanted
to invert the whole thing where you know
vampires can only come out at night this
one can actually only come out in the
daytime
and it uh basically swoops down from the
sky and it lives
essentially i know this sounds sounds
weird but it essentially lives in like
this pod like a coffin-like pod that's
like uh circling the earth like in a
satellite like around the earth and then
it kind of comes down and feeds at
various times
and so into that mix you have a group of
soldiers in iraq who actually kind of
see this like during the gulf war and
they see this thing and it just like
tears the [ __ ] this is a very gory uh
tale
and it just like tears the [ __ ] out of
them and they actually all see it and so
it's kind of like
them it kind of jumps back and forth in
time with all of the guys like all the
soldiers that knew each other and
you know them sharing stories about what
they saw and figuring out how they're
going to destroy it so it's so that's
like a really good story as well like a
really uh kind of original take like on
a vampire story which i thought was also
really cool
and uh the next one is city of the dog
which is kind of
it's sort of i thought it was kind of
like a werewolf story but i think it's
more like a ghoul type of story
and this one uh he said was actually a
little bit um autobiographical in the
sense that it's set in the early 90s in
albany new york where a lot of his
stories are actually set in upstate new
york which presumably where he lives so
he knows a lot about that
and it's almost kind of like
it's like a like an awkward relationship
drama kind of it's just kind of like
these college students like the guy like
the main protagonist and you know him
and his girlfriend like his girlfriend
cheated on him and he can't get over it
and then he ends up like through some
circumstances he ends up living with the
guy who
uh who the girlfriend slept with who was
a friend of hers and so that's kind of
this awkward situation but then uh his
girlfriend like disappears
and uh it comes to be known that there's
like kind of something lurking around
like underneath the city that maybe had
something to do with her disappearance
so there's uh that as well
then we have the weirdest story the mo
and the most lovecraftian one
this one was actually um
it's kind of like
this one was first written he said for
an anthology and the anthology was
supposed to be what would happen to the
earth if like the lovecraftian old ones
like did what they wanted like took over
right so you had to write a story that
was set after that like what the world
would look like so this story is called
the shallows and this is by far the
weirdest one i think uh in the sense
that
it's just this guy who's just like a
regular middle-aged guy and he still
lives in his house because apparently
like you know cthulhu and all them like
didn't didn't get him
um but most everybody is gone like
everything has kind of been blasted out
of existence so it's just kind of like
him and
this
little crab creature that he talks to
and they just kind of like do the rounds
of their house and like do gardening and
stuff so it's it's a very very bizarre
story and then he can kind of see
these weird like
it's hard it's hard to explain uh you
could he can see like these kind of like
weird curtain type things that he where
he can see into like not necessarily
other dimensions but he can kind of see
like other stuff that's going on so yeah
if you're into lovecraftian fiction you
probably really really dig that one
um but it's by far the weirdest one i
didn't actually i got that it was
lovecraftian but i didn't uh immediately
get that it was like after the old ones
had like taken over the earth so i was
glad that he kind of like clarified that
at the end i was like okay well that
makes a lot more sense then but that's
the anthology that that was in uh you
know
at first
the next one
is actually sort of a werewolf story
kind of a werewolf slasher movie type
thing but again
not really what he does is he kind of
takes these types of things but he then
he does other things with him like makes
them metafictions or you know plays with
the format a little bit which like i
said i really like that i kind of like
that experimental uh kind of thing he's
got going on
so it's called the revel
and it's basically
it's good because it's kind of like a
really good
werewolf story in its own right but it's
also kind of like breaking down the
tropes of werewolf stories or even
slasher movies or horror movies in
general
so it's kind of hard to explain but
there's kind of like it's almost written
as though it's a paper
on horror movie tropes but it's still a
good werewolf story also and you know
what i mean so it's kind of like hard to
explain like i said but a lot of these
stories i know i keep saying that but a
lot of these stories are really hard to
explain if you're not reading them just
because again they're sort of they're so
experimental and he just does kind of
like interesting things so so when you
say what it's about it's kind of hard to
express what it's about you have to kind
of like read it and like get involved in
it
uh the next story is a get is another
vignette and was actually written for
almost the same reason or a similar
reason uh to the kids one where he was
writing it where everybody decided they
were gonna write stories about how this
real dude like got killed
this was uh kind of the same situation
this story is called june 1987
hitchhiking mr norris
and this one i think was actually
written
uh about a real person laird barron
who's another writer
and i think what happened was all these
writers got together and said let's to
be funny let's do the same thing let's
write a story about laird baron who is a
real person and uh it's just like this i
think it was called the secret life of
laird baron so it didn't have to be
anything dark necessarily because some
of the stories i heard were funny but
you just had to like make up some crazy
[ __ ] that laird baron had happened like
in his life
so uh so john langan wrote this one
which was essentially about him
uh the dangers of hitchhiking him
getting picked up by this hitchhiker who
was kind of a serial killer but the
serial killer has
a much larger mission let's uh put it
like that so uh so yeah so again laird
baron the protagonist of this is
actually a real person and this was
again written you know to cheer him up
or to be funny or whatever and all these
writers wrote one and they all put it on
uh they all put it on their blogs for
that day like on the same day
now the last story in here which is a
novella pretty sure i mean this one and
technicolor are vying for my favorites i
like them for different reasons
the last one is called mother of stone
and this one man if you're really into
like mythology and particularly like you
know not necessarily even urban legends
but just urban legends slash
like old mythology then you will really
be into this one because this one is
kind of it's written in the second
person which
you don't see much and the reason you
don't see much see that much is because
it's really hard to do without coming
off across is like really
irritating but to its credit uh this
story did not
it didn't like stand out to me at all it
didn't like you know it occurred to me
when i started reading it oh it's in the
second person but it didn't um really
interfere with my enjoyment of it i have
read some other things that were in
second person that just got tedious
after a while but this one absolutely
does not
so this one is framed like
from the point of view of someone who is
doing a paper or thesis
on
a particular type of mythology and they
became interested in this
urban legend or what they think is an
urban legend going around in upstate new
york
and what ended up happening was that
there was this uh place it was an inn
in this town
and while they were digging
uh on the grounds like they were
building i can't remember why they were
why they were digging i did they were
like expanding it or something like that
and while they were digging they found
this really creepy
statue like kind of like a full-size
statue
that looked like
maybe like ancient greek or roman kind
of style but not quite and it was really
really detailed and like really really
beautifully done
and the statue was of a very very
pregnant woman
without a head and i'm and i don't mean
that like the statue oh the head fell
off like the venus de milo or something
like that no it was sculpted to not have
a head to start with
so uh everyone's kind of like wigged out
about it and then everybody got even
more wigged out about it when it so
happened that a pregnant woman who was
driving past the inn one day got into a
horrible car accident which decapitated
her
so after that like this sort of legend
started around maybe the statue was
cursed or whatever and then this local
woman
like kind of uh bought the statue and
put it in the in the end or she you know
they found it on the ground so she put
it in the dining room of the inn and uh
people started like getting really
weirded out by it like it started to
bleed like from the neck and all this
other stuff so um i mean just the
thought of that and the way he describes
what this statue looked like and the
[ __ ] that it was doing was like super
super creepy and like i said i love all
this kind of like mythology stuff and so
you're basically following this
researcher who is trying to get to the
bottom of
you know who made this uh statue why is
it here what is it for
um you know all are all of these crazy
stories like people kept seeing that
then they started seeing like ghosts of
like headless women and [ __ ] like that
like what is all that about so they're
trying to get to the bottom of it this
was by far like the creepiest story and
this one and the poe one um were again
like they i can't decide which one i
like i think i maybe i like this one
slightly more just because
even though um because i feel like the
poe one was a little
format wise was a little stranger
because it was kind of framed through
like someone lecturing to a to a class i
don't know i think i liked them for
similar reasons now that i'm thinking
about it because they're both
dealing with like an investigation where
there's like a weird thing that needs to
be explained and then you're having
somebody like go back through time sort
of and like
try to get to the ball like try to tie
together all these tendrils of like
where this legend came from or where
this story came from or something like
that and i really really like
stories like that um so i think that's
why i responded to those two the most
but yeah those two probably my favorite
i think the last one slightly slightly
more just because that the the image of
this uh of this [ __ ] statue like a
pregnant woman with like no head uh that
bleeds and [ __ ] like that it's just like
really creepy and disturbing and i just
like i really really liked that a lot uh
so after that so you get that and then
uh there's like a little bit of an
interview and then there's uh writer's
notes where he said
you know which anthology the story was
written for like what the theme was even
well sometimes what happens that he
would get asked to be in an anthology
and he's like and then like i started
writing a story and then i got
distracted and wrote something else and
i didn't make the deadline and so it
didn't get it there you know what i mean
i'm like yeah okay i've been there but
yeah so um but some of them did actually
appear in the anthologies that they were
uh supposed to appear in so it's it was
really good to like get the insight as
to
where he got the ideas for for things
you know what i mean because i really
like that since i'm a writer as well so
yeah um if you've ever i can't remember
like i said i'm sorry i can't remember
who it was that recommended this book to
me but
thank you very much because i really
really did like this a lot and we'll
definitely be um looking up some of his
other stuff
um and i really like i don't i feel like
i don't read as many short story
collections as i probably should because
honestly i really like to write short
stories that's like my preferred medium
but uh for whatever reason i don't read
as many short story collections as i'd
like to and i i don't know why that is
because i actually really do like short
story collections so you know it's it's
kind of cool that i got one thrown in
there uh every now and then but yeah so
if you've read uh any john langan if
you've read this book i think one of his
big uh more recent books was called the
fisherman that's because
amazon kept like um
recommending that to me so i'll probably
get around to that as well but you know
so i'll definitely be reading some more
this guy's stuff because i really like
his style uh like i said it's very
elegant and i really really i don't know
i just really like the way he describes
things and like his imagination and the
way he plays with
uh different literary forms and tropes
and stuff like that i found that really
uh i i don't know i just find that
really cool and it kind of it kind of
lines up with the way i like to
approach my own stories as well so i
thought that was kind of awesome but
yeah um so let me know if you've read
the wide carniver sky what you thought
about it and that will do it for this
tomes of terror i will see you guys on
the next one
bye